isn't Charlie Sheen on this one yeah
Charlie Sheen makes an appearance yeah
Charlie Sheen's he's in the triler yeah
Chuck Lori and Charlie Sheen you know
they kind of parted ways after two and
they had that big blowout and this is
kind of the reunion of Chuck Lory and
Charlie Sheen so I I collect uh he plays
himself so he's he's he's running a a
poker game out of a a rehab facility
that he used to go to and he's not he's
not in the rehab he's just running the
poker game and I go to collect money cuz
I'm his bookie and he's in the episode
so wa so how was Charlie was he was he
cool he's cool great great guy very
humble very quiet you know very quiet
very professional I mean this guy's been
acting God knows 40 years running line
yeah
yeah back in he was did he reflect at
all on that time where no that never
brought up uh wait so you didn't when
you're hanging with him I know as a
comedian and there's part of you that's
like just [__] tell me I ain't I
ain't that guy I don't yeah I don't
think he's that guy you couldn't look at
my mustache without bringing it up but
that's different I know but this is this
we're talking about we're talking about
like a this guy is traumatic point of
his life I'm bring that fact you comp
make a really good point the fact you
compare to your mustache I'm a crazy
person I think that's what we realized
after that moment right there you're
right thank you yeah no there was there
was no mention of that you know I'm kept
it
professional profession I feel like yeah
for you private lives are private lives
and that's what yeah whatever you do and
but also what a great idea because who
is not going to at least tap into one
episode outside of your fans like your
fans are going to show up but the world
that doesn't know or doesn't care yet to
see your show but it's like what is
Charlie Sheen up to is going to tap in
yeah you would think it uh and he's a
stud acting wise great he's great and
where did the character come from the
bookie was it your creation was it Chuck
nothing Chuck Chuck and Nick Bai Nick
Bai who was a writer who is involved in
gambling he he he's involved in that
world he likes to gamble and he knows
the ins and outs of of bookies and and
whatnot they said hey I pitched him a
story about my life yeah but then I'm
like as I'm pitching I go do I really
want to be me again can I pitch you
something real quick that might already
have been made but I think it's the
wildest
story I this's one I told you
about World War II America has to go and
kind of [__] up Italy a little bit they
have to find a way to enter
Europe they find out that the Italian
mob in Sicily is very against
musolini so they connect with Lucky
Luciano in New York and ask if they can
get help from the Italian mob to map out
Sicily so they can invade from the south
so the mob in New York and Sicily help
helps the American Army enter Italy and
rid it of the Tyrant that is imagine a
mob movie where you can root you're
rooting for the like how has this not
been made no and this this might show my
ignorance is this a true story this is a
true story no no no this is this is a
true [__] story I'm like there's all
these fake mob stories you have the
craziest real mob story that involves
real dude like Lucky Luciano I'm pretty
sure it's lucky righted a real [__]
guy
they get to be the pseudo Good Guys
during this it does sound like a story
like an Italian Uncle made up though
right you know it you know you know we
killed the Nazis right we got them out
it you know we ended World War II like
really is that true but I mean how is
that isn't that like a I think it's a
fabulous story and I think I'm surprised
you wasted the pitch
here cut it cut that into Charlie Shan
cut both of those take that take that
this real time we're oper husky I is the
was what it was called I had no idea but
no that is a great premise for a movie I
like it you should cut that out though
and you should pitch that cut it out we
sell it together guys we sell it we
going together we take it there we need
an Italian to to help I'll just be there
and he could do the pitch and I'll just
be there
as appropriate Sicilian culture so we
need a we need some more blood in there
did you have to talk to real bookies for
this role I asked Chuck should I do a
deep dive you know cuz I'm like want to
be collaborative and whatnot he goes no
don't don't you know don't don't don't
you know we want you we want you not
what a traditional how much of you did
you feel comfortable bringing on to this
uh a lot okay a lot I mean I I I play a
very sympathetic bookie uh I'm not out
to like break legs and and and and bust
heads um but yeah he wanted more kind of
my my take on it not so much yeah I I I
you know researched a little bit about B
bookies and talk to people who use
bookies I I've never used a bookie
before but it was interesting to find
out a bookie in this particular
landscape of how he's navigating
possible pending Doom of the State of
California legalizing gambling kind of
where does that leave him so and I also
like the fact that we go into a lot of
different areas in Los Angeles like uh
we're collecting money from a trust fund
kid we're collecting money from a
housewife a college kid and and
everybody in between so it takes you
into a lot of different environment
where it's like oh okay this is this is
cool and it plays to my comedy because
it's you know you know observe and and
and and and get to a chance to play a
lot with with the environment that's
really smart yeah there was a show
called high maintenance it was like a
really successful web series that HBO
did where we delivery guy went to a
bunch of different houses and this is
that but more interesting it's a bookie
which is just all automatically we're
this something aash does a lot it's like
when you have this great idea that you
think is unique he just likes to remind
you that this been done before yeah this
is he does this five times aart but this
is better I was shocked when I said that
thing about World War II he wasn't oh
yeah that was already done Indians did
that a long time ago yeah that's how we
got the British out of that yeah you
know what you're doing you're signing up
at prize picks use the promo code
Schultz and they will match your initial
deposit up to $100 that means you put in
100 you get 100 for free that's all you
got to do price.com promo code Schultz
let's get back to the show you used to
be into gambling a little bit right yeah
I used to gamble would you get throw it
out a little bit the only reason I was
gambling uh my reason for it was while I
was working at the Four Seasons Hotel I
did not like necessarily waiting on
tables I got I got burned out so when I
would go to Vegas I would gamble hoping
I would win so I could take off work and
concentrate more on standup obviously
that that didn't work I uh I didn't win
um but later I found out the only only
way you really leave a casino with money
is performing there and that's the route
I went what was your game when you
played though Blackjack and Wheel of
Fortune the best game the best game
break down Wheel of
Fortune The Wheel of Fortune slot
machine no how much you throwing in per
game uh it was I think $3 to get the the
the spin and back then when you're
making a grand a week at a comedy club
$3 is a lot of money up so that's that
was my game and there was a there was a
a machine at Treasure Island it it used
to pay in Lo loose next time I went in
there they remodeled the whole thing
I so of course I tried to find
it and I lost everything what was the
most you were up though I left Los Vegas
and again this is this is pittance with
$1,500 and I thought I was I thought I
was I thought I was loaded I thought man
I you beat it they're G have to close it
down oh yeah